[Music]
the vision
came from the recommendations
of the advisory group that was formed by
the quebec government
that
worked together for about a year
to develop the master plan for an
ecosystem in artificial intelligence
here in montreal and all over the
province of quebec and at the center of
that ecosystem we felt
it was very important that we have a
world-class research institute miele's
growth since its inception is actually
quite phenomenal the size of the
institute has more than tripled in a
very short period of time whether that's
measured by a number of researchers
number of students number of projects
number of partners it's unique in the
world on a number of fronts number one
it brings together two universities
universal and mcgill university
therefore two cultures two languages and
so a much broader scope from the
academic standpoint
so to have brought together
the continuum the complete chain from
ideation to industry application on
specific projects is absolutely unique
and that's what makes us
efficient
that's what will allow us to remain in
the top tier institutes in the world
forever i think there are two
fundamental elements
the most important is productivity and
competitiveness for our enterprises here
in quebec for all canadian enterprise
the second is talent and it's it's at
the center of success today it is an
extremely
competitive world
for talent if you have an institute like
mila that attracts the best talent
you have a good chance to stay in the
game and maybe even win the game
[Music]
you